hi I'm some Siemens and I'll be
answering your questions from Twitter
this is tennis support Chad Castel when
you look for a coach we're looking for
someone who's just gonna psychologically
motivate you would you hire someone who
changes your strokes strategy I think at
this point in time like with me being so
old I think that I'm kind of like stuck
in my ways and I play tennis so I think
someone who definitely understands me
well someone who gets me changing my
strokes like isn't really a thing now
but I think like strategy now is like
really important like as you get older
well yeah I think that's what I look for
in a coach someone who like really gets
me and understands me
writer dev someone needs to invent
cooling paint or cement for tennis
courts and playgrounds to help reduce to
on core temperature anybody up for it
I would totally invest in your company
writer Deb if you came up with that
because I've been on the court playing
when it's super hot and is not fun your
feet start to burn and they get sweaty
and like yuck so I would definitely if
you're on Shark Tank all invested Neil
okay
Arcola Richie poor how many hours a day
should a junior player practice
I don't know and there's a lot of
factors in that like are you
home-schooled
are you trying to go to college or you
trying to turn pro how old are you where
do you play are you at an academy do you
take lessons you play in a junior
program there's like so many things that
go into that but like I say if you're
homeschooled and you're like trying to
go to college on a full scholarship I
think you should probably play like
three or four hours a day it's like not
too much not too little it's a lot
though it's a commitment that gone guy
at schmuck
why are there so many lefties in tennis
is there any advantage from serving with
the left hand I totally wish I was lefty
cuz I'd be so good if I was why there's
so many lefties I honestly don't think
that they're that many lefties to be
honest like I'd say like in the top
hundred there's probably like for the
girls side there's probably like
2:15 maybe which is not a lot out of a
hundred people is there any advantage
from serving with the lefthand I think
it's just like a different angle and
obviously since like the ratio from
lefty to rise is like totally uneven I
think that there is like a pretty good
advantage of your left hand in which why
I wish I was left-handed
ACP guy if there were to be a fifth
Grand Slam something that is a mix of
different services would be cool ideally
something where the higher seat gets to
pick the surface like a home court
advantage clay grass and hard court
would be the three options thoughts I'm
assuming there to be like a lot of prize
money for this and that we men and women
and it would be yeah but like home court
advantage is like at your home so then
where would this event take place we
have to they have a lot to talk through
to get to the bottom of that - my
favorite type of chord to play on is red
clay I love playing in Europe I think
it's like the best clay courts in the
world obviously the French Open but yeah
I like playing on hard courts -
obviously growing up in the u.s. we play
in a lot of hard courts and playing a
lot of like hard true which is like
green clay but my favorite surface is
red clay Nicholas Juarez who's the
toughest opponent you've ever faced I'd
say probably Serena Williams Simona
Halep Li Na I played her one time before
I wish I could have played couldn't I
sir she's like my favorite player of all
time and she retired before I got good
huh took me too long Sam Richards is it
possible to be in love with the backhand
slice have you never been in love with
anything else before I definitely
wouldn't I mean yeah it's possible you
love what you love right can't help what
you love and who you love and what you
like and that's it back in slice I'm not
I'm about it oh wait fear the Kerch -
tennis people on here do you know of any
fun / good exercises to practice
forehand volleys beginner
I don't know I'd say like if you really
want to practice water you probably like
feed like someone feed duck a coach Fiji
balls or like go practice on the ball
like cuz then you know the ball always
coming back and like you can kind of
control the speed so I mean yeah I'd say
like for beginners like either someone
feeding it to you or like hitting
against the wall which is still cool
people don't like to do it but it
in my opinion the Zen dragoon thinking
hurt being hit by a tennis ball being
served yeah you don't get out the wind
get hit that yeah it hurt all right
Laura Mac Mirchi the tennis skirts slash
shorts have ball pockets no way these
women just put a ball inside of their
shorts and it's a they're not
interfering or falling out during a
rally right
no because you like put it in your booty
shorts and let me show you this is a
tennis skirt right and under here
there's like a little short right and
you put the ball in here and like these
are so tight to your skin and that they
just like the ball just like sits in
here like can show you but like this and
it's so tight to you it doesn't fall out
like I don't know I've never had it fall
out like all the years I've been playing
tennis it's never falling out so I don't
know okay
best dress fYI do you have to be a
professional ball retriever to work a
professional match honestly I think at
the US Open and like in the Grand Slams
you have to go through like a whole
process and like they pick you and you
have to run like a certain amount of
like tie like they tie me for your
Sprint's and I think they have like
levels and then I also think that the
better you get like the higher matches
you get to do because I've had some of
the same ball people for like years like
since I was like younger if you really
love tennis you get to be around like
Roger Federer and Serena Williams and
all these people that like you obviously
probably look up to so any of the day I
think it's probably like a cool job like
you're on people you love and then get
paid that was a good question that was
like the best question we had so far
okay Billy bond bond double O three
three tennis agree disagree that ball
boys and girls should should or should
not have to touch the sweaty towels of
players I mean one of the people say
that comes with the territory
now if someone's sick or bleeding or
whatever then that's nasty but so what I
mean everybody has sweat and you kind of
they throw it they don't like lay it on
you like I don't know I think that just
comes with the job I think yeah kind of
gross but mmm
Chris a Fischer I was watching the WTA
finals highlights against Burton's from
18-year ground show so it's so
effortless I saw you hit B is sitting in
a chair when you have the toe injury do
you think it can help with form my form
needs work well first of all I broke my
foot and I my toe
I wish it was my toe cuz I would've been
a lot easier to recover from I don't
know I think maybe the the video just
looked good cuz I have already good for
him I don't know what you would like
teach someone like if you were sitting
in a chair and say you just work on your
form and lose the chair okay yep blind
tbh tennis experts how does the serve
work in the first game of the first set
I assume there's a coin toss to decide
who gets to pick who certain players
always defer their serve so that they
serve in the second game of the set okay
so obviously in the match starts they
like flip a coin obviously who wins you
can pick serve or return and then or you
can pick side which is like I'll take
that side and then the other person gets
a pick serve return and then or you can
defer which is like the other person
gets to pick first some players do
actually like try to hold serve so that
they can serve like make the person
serve out the end of a set look if
they're like down a break I don't know
whatever I just no server return that's
that I don't I can't calculate all the
other stuff it's too much thank you so
much for your questions I'll see you
next time on tennis support